Hi there, it's Marianne here. Before we dive into today's episode, I want to quickly let you know about something exciting that's happening right now. If you've ever wondered how to create income that works for you, rather than constantly trading your time for money, then you'll love the Race to Recurring Revenue Challenge with my business mentor, Lisa Johnson. This challenge is designed to help you build sustainable income streams. And whether you're an aspiring psychologist, a mental health professional, or in a completely different field,
大家好，我是玛丽安。在深入今天的节目之前，我想快速通知大家一件目前正在发生的激动人心的事。如果你曾经想过如何创造能够为你带来收益的收入，而不是不断用时间去换取金钱，那么你一定会喜欢我的商业导师丽莎·约翰逊（Lisa Johnson）发起的“向持续收入冲刺挑战赛”（Race to Recurring Revenue Challenge）。这项挑战旨在帮助你建立可持续的收入来源。无论你是有志成为心理学家的人、心理健康专业人士，还是身处完全不同的领域，
the principles can work for you. There are also wonderful prizes to be won directly by Lisa herself. And if you join the challenge by my link, you can be in with a chance of winning a one-to-one hours coaching with me, Dr. Marianne Trent. Do you want to know more? Of course you do. Head to my link tree, Dr. Marianne Trent, or check out my social media channels, or send me a quick DM and I'll get you all the details. Right, let's get on with today's episode. If you're looking to become a psychologist, then let this be your guide. episode. With Dr. Marianne Trent Hi, welcome along to the Aspiring Psychologist podcast.
这些原则对你同样适用。还有由丽莎亲自送出的精美奖品。如果你通过我的链接加入挑战，你将有机会赢得与我——玛丽安·特ント博士（Dr. Marianne Trent）一对一一小时的辅导。你想了解更多吗？当然想。前往我的 Linktree（Dr. Marianne Trent），或者查看我的社交媒体频道，或者给我发个简短的私信，我就会把所有详情发给你。好了，让我们继续今天的节目。如果你正期待成为一名心理学家，那么让这成为你的指南吧。节目主持：玛丽安·特ント博士。嗨，欢迎来到《有志心理学家播客》。
I am Dr. Marianne Trent and I'm a qualified clinical psychologist. Thank you so much for coming back regularly to listen to what I've got to say and what my guests have got to say too. Or this might be your first ever episode. If it is, then welcome along. Why not subscribe whilst you're here? And if you're watching on YouTube, subscribe, like, comment, engage, do all those good things. If you are listening on Apple podcasts, even if you're not, I'd love it if you would take a moment to go along and rate and review the podcast series. If you really like the podcast series and you think it's useful, I'd love it if you consider buying me a cup of herbal tea,
我是玛丽安·特ント博士，是一名合格的临床心理学家。非常感谢大家定期回来收听我和嘉宾们的分享。或者这可能是你的第一次收听。如果是的话，欢迎加入。何不在收听的同时订阅呢？如果你在 YouTube 上观看，请订阅、点赞、评论、互动，做所有这些美好的事情。如果你在 Apple Podcasts 上收听，即使没有，我也希望你能花一点时间来给这个播客系列评分和评论。如果你真的很喜欢这个播客系列并且觉得它很有用，我希望你能考虑请我喝一杯花草茶，
which you can do by going to my link tree on my socials and clicking donate. It does cost me a few hundred pounds a month to produce the podcast so if you do find the content helpful and you can afford to buy me a cup of herbal tea I'd be so very grateful. There is also a link in the show notes. So I know because many of you have been in contact that you are all at different stages of your career. Some of you are doing GCSEs, some of you are doing A-levels, some of you are doing your degree, some of you are doing your master's, some of you are doing your doctorate or your PhD, some of you are even already qualified. So we've got a really big, broad area. Some of you are even working in an unrelated career, considering coming across and jumping ship to the good shit psychology. So I try to create content that's going to be useful for you, whatever level you're at.
你可以通过访问我社交媒体上的 Linktree 并点击捐赠来做到这一点。制作这个播客每月确实要花我几百英镑，所以如果你觉得这些内容很有帮助，并且能够负担得起请我喝一杯花草茶，我将不胜感激。节目简介中也有一个链接。我知道，因为你们中的许多人联系过我，你们正处于职业生涯的不同阶段。有些人正在考 GCSE，有些人正在考 A-level，有些人正在读本科，有些人正在读硕士，有些人正在读博士，有些人甚至已经具备了资质。所以我们涉及的范围非常广泛。你们中甚至有些人从事着不相关的职业，正考虑转行，跳槽到心理学这个好行业。因此，我努力创作对你有用内容，无论你处于什么水平。
And I will make sure that I'm trying where possible to reference how this can be relevant for you wherever you're at right now. So obviously interviews can come up at any time of the year. Exams tend to be sort of summer-ish but if you're doing modular courses they might be all year long as well. Right now as I record this, this is going out in March, but I'm recording this in February 2023. We are in the swing of interview season for educational psychology and clinical psychology. We are starting to hear whether people have got interviews. So I thought it'd be really useful, because I know we all have busy, busy lives, to think about some of the revision or learning techniques that don't work as well as we might think they do. And then come in and talk to you
我会确保在可能的情况下提及这些内容如何与你当前所处的位置息息相关。很显然，面试可能在一年中的任何时候进行。考试往往集中在夏天左右，但如果你学的是模块化课程，它们也可能贯穿全年。我录制这段音频时正值三月，但我是在 2023 年 2 月录制的。我们正处于教育心理学和临床心理学面试季的高峰期。我们开始陆续听到谁获得了面试通知。所以我想，既然我知道我们大家的生活都非常忙碌，那么思考一些实际上并不如我们想象中那么有效的复习或学习技巧会非常有用，然后我们再来探讨
about the ones that evidence has shown us. We love a bit of evidence, don't we? That evidence has shown us does work. I'm not going to leave you high and dry though. As ever, we do have our compassionate Q&A session. So if you do need or want some extra support with the application or interview process, regardless of what you're at right now, where you're at. You can come along to the sessions and ask me questions. So let me just talk you through the dates we've got for those coming up. Okay, so the Compassionate Q&A dates, they're all free and they're across my socials. A great place to hang out to make sure you catch it is in the free Facebook group, which is the Aspiring Psychologist Community with Dr. Marianne Trent, brackets, free group. You can also catch it live on YouTube. I'm basically Dr. Marianne Trent in all of the
那些经证据证明确实有效的技巧。我们都喜欢证据，不是吗？证据向我们表明确实有效的方法。不过我不会把你晾在一边不管。和往常一样，我们有同理心问答环节。因此，如果你确实需要或想要在申请或面试过程中获得一些额外的支持——无论你现在处于什么阶段。你可以来参加这些环节并向我提问。让我向大家介绍一下我们即将进行的这些日期的安排。好的，同理心问答的日期都是免费的，并且会在我的社交媒体上发布。一个可以确保你不会错过的好地方是免费的 Facebook 群组，即“有志心理学家社群与玛丽安·特ント博士”（Aspiring Psychologist Community with Dr. Marianne Trent，括号里写着免费群组）。你也可以在 YouTube 上观看直播。基本上我在所有
social media places, so you can catch it there. So the first session will be happening on Monday the 13th of March 2023 at 7.30pm and if when you're listening or watching this you're like well that date's already passed Marianne then you'll be able to catch it on replay on my YouTube channel Dr Marianne Trent. Like, subscribe, do all those good things whilst you're there. Come on, be kind. And our second session of this year will be on Monday, the 17th of April 2023 at 7.30pm. And our third will be Tuesday because of the little bank holiday on the Monday, the 2nd of May 2023 at 7.30pm. And if you're listening to this, and it's totally the wrong time of year for you, and you're thinking, well, actually, I'm applying for stuff, I'm not preparing for interviews, then we've got your bases covered there as well. On Dr. Marianne Trent channel, you can access all
社交媒体平台上都叫“玛丽安·特ント博士”，所以你可以在那里找到我。因此，第一场直播将于 2023 年 3 月 13 日星期一晚上 7:30 举行。如果你听到或看到这个的时候觉得“玛丽安，那个日期已经过去了”，那么你将能够在我的 YouTube 频道“Dr Marianne Trent”上观看回放。顺便点赞、订阅，做所有那些美好的事情。拜托，友善一点。我们今年的第二场直播将是 2023 年 4 月 17 日星期一晚上 7:30。由于周一有个小银行假日，第三场将安排在星期二，即 2023 年 5 月 2 日晚上 7:30。如果你听到这个时发现时间完全不对，并且心想“实际上我正在申请其他东西，我不是在准备面试”，那么我们在那方面也为你做好了准备。在玛丽安·特ント博士的频道上，你可以观看
of the replays for previous Q&A sessions for application season, not just interview season two. So let's get on with the content for today's episode. And I do hope you find it useful. So the first of the techniques for preparing for exams and interviews that doesn't really work that well, but evidence suggests we think it works quite well, is rereading. So rereading chapters or notes you've made or, you know, summary things doesn't work as well as other strategies. So this research was put together by a psychologist called Dunlosky. And they found that there was some limited evidence that it does work, but that because it's a passive learning technique, that it sort of works, but it's not the most effective. So yeah, I was, to be honest, blown away because I always thought that was the thing to do. That rereading, you're just rereading a whole book or, you know, particular chapters on
申请季历次问答环节的所有回放，不仅仅是面试季哦。让我们继续今天的内容吧。我希望你觉得它有用。那么，备考和面试中第一种实际上效果不佳、但证据表明我们以为它效果很好的技巧，就是重复阅读。也就是说，重复阅读章节、你做的笔记或者（你知道的）总结性材料，其效果不如其他策略。这项研究是由一位名叫邓洛斯基（Dunlosky）的心理学家整理的。他们发现有有限的证据表明它确实管用，但由于这是一种被动学习技巧，它的效果马马虎虎，并不是最高效的。所以，说实话，我当时惊呆了，因为我一直以为这就是应该做的事。那就是重复阅读，你只是重读整本书，或者（你知道的）关于特定章节
topics was going to blow things out of the park. So if you are also like, what? Then listen on, because I need to tell you more about the other stuff that doesn't work as well as we might think it does. Okay, so the second thing that might well blow your mind is highlighting and underlining. That is one of the things that was absolutely my go-to, lining up the desk, getting all the highlighters ready, getting the little tab markers to mark stuff. That was my bag, baby. But actually, there's been evidence to suggest that not only does it not help with our performance, that sometimes it can hinder our performance, because it means that we are learning things in too narrow a sphere, really. And what it doesn't help us to do is to make inferences. And of course,
主题的内容就能大获成功。所以如果你也觉得“什么？”，那就继续听下去，因为我需要告诉你更多关于那些效果不如我们想象的另外一些方法。好的，第二件可能会让你大跌眼镜的事就是高亮标记和下划线。这绝对是我过去最常用的一招，摆好书桌，准备好所有的荧光笔，准备好小标签来标记东西。那曾是我的强项，宝贝。但实际上，有证据表明，它不仅对我们的表现没有帮助，有时甚至会阻碍我们的表现，因为这意味着我们在一个过于狭窄的领域里学习。它无法真正帮助我们做的是进行推理。当然，
in psychology, being able to link things to other areas can be really, really important. Whereas if we boiled it all down to, you know, one or two lines, then really, our knowledge is not super dense, is it? You know, it's surface level at best. So don't worry, I'm not going to leave you high and dry. I'm not going to leave you with all the stuff that doesn't work and then not tell you about the stuff that does. So listen on or watch on and there's more great things coming too.
在心理学中，能够将事物与其他领域联系起来可能真的非常非常重要。然而，如果我们把它们精简到（你知道的）一两行，那么实际上我们的知识密度并不高，对吧？（你知道的）顶多是浅尝辄止。所以别担心，我不会把你晾在一边。我不会把所有没用的东西都丢给你，却不告诉你哪些才是有用的。所以继续收听或观看，后面还有更多精彩内容。
Now, when people are asked again about whether they feel that highlighting is going to be a useful strategy, they absolutely think it is. And even when they're told that it's not that helpful, they might still like to engage in it because it feels kind of comforting, like a safety blanket. So absolutely carry on doing it if you would like to, but do bear in mind there's other techniques that can skyrocket your performance in interviews and tests too. Okay, so the third thing that isn't working as well as we think it might is summarising or making notes. It's been found, again by Dunlosky, that it's got pretty low utility in helping us learn stuff, helping us remember stuff, helping us recall the stuff when we need to. And the theory is, is we're not summarising effectively or efficiently. And we need to be
现在，当人们再次被问及是否觉得高亮标记是一种有用的策略时，他们绝对认为是的。甚至当被告知它没那么有用时，他们可能仍然喜欢这样做，因为这感觉有点安慰，就像一张安全毯。所以如果你愿意，绝对可以继续这样做，但请记住，还有其他一些技巧也可以让你的面试和测试表现突飞猛进。好的，第三个效果不如我们想象中那么好的事情是总结或做笔记。同样由邓洛斯基发现，它在帮助我们学习、帮助我们记忆、帮助我们在需要时回忆起内容方面的实用性相当低。其理论是，我们并没有进行有效或高效的总结。我们需要
either taught how to do that better better or just give it a miss altogether because there's other strategies that do work better. It's not something that I was taught at school or uni. You might well have been and if you're using advanced skills in summarising, you might be knocking it out the park but many of us are winging it and just doing what we think is going to be best so yeah if you do like these things then do continue to use them but maybe also use the other techniques that I'm going to be talking to you about too if you are a passionate note taker or you want to use modern ways to think about your preparing or testing yourself I have been really loving the remarkable tablet it's a paper-free tablet, which really helps you organize yourself too. If you'd like a £40, I think it's £40 rather than
要么被教导如何做得更好，要么干脆放弃它，因为还有其他策略确实更有效。这不是我在学校或大学里学到的东西。你可能学过，如果你正在运用高级的总结技巧，你可能会大获成功，但我们中的许多人只是在盲目摸索，做我们认为最好的事情。所以，是的，如果你确实喜欢这些东西，那么请继续使用它们，但也许也可以同时使用我接下来要向你介绍的其他技巧。如果你是一个热情的笔记记录者，或者你想用现代化的方式来思考你的准备或自我测试，我一直非常喜欢 Remarkable 平板电脑，它是一款无纸化平板电脑，确实也能帮助你进行自我整理。如果你想要一张 40 英镑（我觉得是 40 英镑而不是
$40 off code, then check out the link in the show notes or send me a DM. So let's take a little break here and I will be back along to talk you through the strategies that are really going to help you get to be where you want to be, whether that's passing your exam, whether that is being able to, you know, do as well as you can in your interviews. I will catch you on the other side of this. You can try the Aspiring Psychologist Collective. The Aspiring Psychologist Collective. Hello, my name is Avalon and I'm an undergraduate psychology student. I really enjoyed reading the Aspiring Psychologist Collective and I really honestly just couldn't put it down. I found it really helpful because as I'm in my final year I'm starting to think about
40 美元）的优惠码，请查看节目说明中的链接或给我发私信。那么我们在这里稍作休息，我稍后会回来，向大家介绍那些真正能帮助你实现目标的策略，无论是通过考试，还是能够在面试中（你知道的）发挥出最佳水平。我们在另一边见。你可以尝试“有志心理学家集体”。有志心理学家集体。你好，我叫阿瓦隆（Avalon），是一名心理学本科生。我真的很喜欢阅读《有志心理学家集体》，说实话，我真的爱不释手。我发现它真的很有帮助，因为作为大四学生，我开始思考
what I'd like to do after uni and up until this point I've been very set on the idea of pursuing an AP role and the Aspiring Psychologist Collective helped me to see that there are so many more options out there that may appeal to me and I'm looking forward to exploring some of these and broadening out my options. And I also really appreciated that people were open about their lived experience and how they navigated this over their psychology journey. I've had lived experience of an eating disorder, so it was really inspiring to hear about how people have brought that into their reflections and how it shaped the clinicians that they are today. Thank you. Okay, welcome back.
毕业后我想做什么，直到现在我一直非常坚定地追求助理心理学家（AP）的职位，《有志心理学家集体》帮助我看到了外面还有那么多可能吸引我的选择，我期待着探索其中的一些选择并拓宽我的选择范围。我也真的很感激大家能够坦诚地分享他们的生活经历以及他们如何在心理学之旅中应对这些经历。我有过进食障碍的生活经历，所以听到大家如何将这一点融入他们的反思中，以及它如何塑造了今天的临床医生，这真的非常鼓舞人心。谢谢。好的，欢迎回来。
So in the first half, we were speaking about the techniques for revision or learning that actually don't serve us as well as we think they do. And that is rereading, highlighting and summarising. So if you have stumbled into this and you want to know why that doesn't serve us as well, then skip back to the start and then come back to this point and we'll pick up from there. If you are still with us, you're listening or watching, then please do like, subscribe, comment and engage. So what works? Great question. So the first of the techniques that's going to start to work really, really well for you is what's called active recall, because that is thought to be much more efficient than just cramming the stuff in there. So the theory is
所以在前半部分，我们讨论了那些实际上并不如我们想象中那么管用的复习或学习技巧。那就是重复阅读、高亮标记和总结。所以如果你是不小心点进来的，想知道为什么这些方法效果不佳，那就跳回开头，然后再回到这里，我们从这里继续。如果你还在和我们在一起，正在收听或观看，请务必点赞、订阅、评论和互动。那么什么才管用？好问题。那么，对你真正非常、非常管用的第一种技巧被称为“主动回忆”（active recall），因为人们认为这比单纯死记硬背要高效得多。所以其理论是
that when we're trying to get stuff out of our brain, it actually strengthens the neural pathways for us to be able to do so when we need to get it. So we need to be able to practice getting that stuff that we've learned out. We might do that by using practice tests, by doing practice interviews and popping ourselves on the spot. And we might be able to do past exam papers as well. And you might be like, well, seriously, how much of a difference can this make? And there's some evidence to suggest that it's 10 to 15% increase in performance just by having one practice test at the end of each study session that you do. And there's other evidence to suggest that doing that can boost your performance between 30 and 60 percent. Wow imagine that if whatever recent exam or interview situation you were in your performance was boosted
当我们试图将东西从大脑中提取出来时，它实际上会加强神经通路，以便我们在需要时能够做到这一点。因此我们需要练习将学到的东西提取出来。我们可以通过使用模拟测试、进行模拟面试并让自己猝不及防来做到这一点。我们也可以做过去的考试真题。你可能会想，“说真的，这能带来多大区别呢？”有证据表明，在完成的每个学习单元结束时进行一次模拟测试，表现就可以提升 10% 到 15%。还有其他证据表明，这样做可以将你的表现提升 30% 到 60%。哇，想象一下，无论你最近参加了什么考试或面试，你的表现都得到了提升
by 30 to 60 percent and again you might be like no that can't be as good as me rereading that chapter four times. That is totally the way to do it. Evidence suggests that people that used active learning during four study sessions performed better than people who just read a chapter four times. Interestingly, students actually did rate in research that they thought active recall was going to be the least effective strategy for helping them to improve their performance. But it was found to be one of the most effective strategies. So what have you got to lose? Give it a while. Try out some active recall at the end of your study sessions and see how you go. So I'm going to take you through some techniques to help you do active recall because you might be like I don't really really know how to do that so let me guide you through those. There's other ideas in a book called Make It
30% 到 60%。同样，你可能会想，“不，这不可能比我把那一章读四遍更好。”那绝对是正确的做法。证据表明，在四个学习单元中使用了主动学习的人，其表现比仅仅读了一章四遍的人要好。有趣的是，研究中的学生实际上评价说，他们认为主动回忆是对帮助他们提高表现最无效的策略。但它被证明是最有效的策略之一。所以你有什么好失去的呢？试一试吧。在学习结束时尝试一些主动回忆，看看效果如何。我将带你了解一些帮助你进行主动回忆的技巧，因为你可能会觉得“我真的不知道该怎么做”，所以让我来指导你。一本名为《认知天性》（Make It
Stick as well and I will link that in the show notes. Wanted to also thank somebody who I follow for inspiring this podcast episode Ali Abdaal and he's a medic but I thought I'd make this specifically relevant to my psychology audience. So you might well be a big fan of flashcards you might well make your own flashcards but technology has moved on a little bit and there is a flashcard app that you can use as well. And it's called Anki, A-N-K-I. And what you can do is you can set the question or the prompt on the front of the flashcard. And then on the back is the information that you need to be able to recall. So you're aiming to help that prompt on the front dig deep into your brain and help you with the active recall, help you with
Stick）的书里也有其他观点，我会把链接放在节目说明中。我还想感谢一位我关注的、启发了这个播客节目的博主阿里·阿布达尔（Ali Abdaal），他是一名医生，但我想把这期节目做得特别贴合我的心理学听众。所以你很可能是抽认卡（flashcards）的超级粉丝，你很可能会制作自己的抽认卡，但技术已经有了一些进步，现在也有你可以使用的抽认卡应用程序。它叫做 Anki（A-N-K-I）。你可以做的是在抽认卡正面设置问题或提示。然后在背面则是你需要能够回忆起来的信息。所以你的目标是帮助正面的那个提示深深地刻入你的大脑，并帮助你进行主动回忆，帮助你
getting that information out there. And with the Anki app, which is free, I believe, you can also rate how easy you find that. Easy, medium and hard. And if you rate it as hard, it might well crop up again in 10 minutes. If you rate it as easy, it might not crop up again in your flashcard practice for a couple of weeks, because you still need to be able to access the easy stuff, don't you? But of course, the stuff that's harder to learn, you're going to need more exposure to. So one of the things that can be really tricky and that people tell me is really tricky in psychology is being able to remember all of the studies and the research that they need to be able to quote and cite. You know, sometimes you might just write Smith et al,
把那些信息提取出来。通过免费的 Anki 应用程序，我相信你还可以评估你觉得它有多容易。分为简单、中等和困难。如果你将它评为困难，它可能在 10 分钟后再次出现。如果你将它评为简单，它可能在几周内都不会再次出现在你的抽认卡练习中，因为你仍然需要能够获取简单的内容，对吧？但当然，那些较难学习的内容，你需要更多地接触。所以，心理学中非常棘手且大家告诉我非常棘手的事情之一，就是能够记住他们需要引用和引用的所有研究。你知道，有时你可能只会写史密斯等人，
you know, 2020. But it's really can be useful to remember as many of the authors as we can and of course be able to convincingly talk about the research so um being able to pop on the on the flash card the names of the authors and the year and then on the back giving yourself a little summary of the research and then being able to almost regurgitate that when you need to, either in an exam situation or in an interview situation, will make you look really, really whizzy. You can even use that app when you're learning that information to begin with. So rather than taking notes, which we've been told is not that effective, you can literally make those flashcards as your notes as you're going along. And then use those as part of your active recall,
（你知道的）2020 年。但能够记住尽可能多的作者，并且当然能够令人信服地谈论这项研究，真的会非常有用；嗯，能够在抽认卡上写下作者的姓名和年份，然后在背面给自己一个关于研究的小结，然后在需要时几乎可以把它背出来——无论是在考试情境下还是在面试情境下——都会让你看起来非常、非常厉害。你甚至可以在刚开始学习这些信息时就使用那个应用程序。因此，与其做笔记（我们之前被告知那并不是很有效），你不如在学习的过程中直接把这些做成抽认卡。然后将其作为主动回忆的一部分，
either at the end of a lecture or the end of a study session. It's that ability to test yourself as you go along, that is going to really lay the foundations for that active recall. It's not just passive strategies. Okay, and the next of the strategies that's going to supercharge your abilities is making notes, but with the book closed. So read what you need to read, and then make notes based on what you can remember. And then when you've made your notes have a read through the book again see what you've missed and then close the book and try to add to that on what you've missed. You might well want to use strategies such as spider diagrams when you're doing that to link your learning to. And the final of our techniques for really boosting your techniques in active learning is rather than just
无论是在一堂课结束时还是在一个学习单元结束时。这种边学边测试自己的能力，才是真正为主动回忆奠定基础的关键。这不仅仅是被动的策略。好的，接下来能让你的能力超常发挥的策略是：合上书本做笔记。阅读你需要阅读的内容，然后根据你能记住的内容做笔记。然后当你做完笔记后，再读一遍书，看看你漏掉了什么，接着合上书，试着把你漏掉的部分补充进去。你在这样做时可能希望使用诸如蜘蛛图之类的策略来将你的学习内容联系起来。我们在真正提升主动学习技巧方面的最后一个技巧不是
making traditional notes is to write questions for yourself based on the material so as you're learning it write yourself questions and then answer them so why this works is because it really ramps up the cognitive effort involved in your learning. It's not purely passive. We're not just sponges. We're not going to soak it up. When we do more with the stuff that we're learning, it's more likely that those neural pathways are going to be thrown down in the right way, which is going to help us be able to find them again when we need to be able to get that stuff out of our brain. So I hope you found this really useful. In summary, we want to be, you know, if it feels comforting, if it feels like a safety blanket, then you can still carry on
做传统的笔记，而是根据材料为自己写问题——所以在学习时给自己写问题，然后回答它们。为什么这很有效？因为它大大提高了学习过程中的认知投入。它不是纯粹被动的。我们不只是海绵。我们不会只是吸收它。当我们对自己所学的东西做更多的事情时，那些神经通路就更有可能以正确的方式铺设，这将有助于我们在需要从大脑中提取这些东西时再次找到它们。希望你觉得这真的很有用。总而言之，如果你觉得这样做很舒服，如果它感觉像一张安全毯，那么你仍然可以继续
making notes, summarizing, highlighting, and rereading. But really, in order to do ourselves the ultimate favor, it's really important that we seek to do as much active recall as we can. And ways I would do this is I'd probably, over dinner, get my husband to ask me what I've learned today that's another simple way that you could use or you know if you speak to your mum or a friend on the phone you could say you know could you check in with me even on whatsapp and ask what I've learned today and you know then parrot it out either as a voice note or if you like to type you could type it out so you're really strengthening those neural pathways or perhaps you could look at using your supervision sessions to talk about
做笔记、总结、高亮和重复阅读。但实际上，为了对自己好到极致，非常重要的一点是，我们要尽量多地进行主动回忆。我可能会采用的方法是，在晚餐时让我的丈夫问我今天学到了什么——这是你可以使用的另一种简单方法，或者（你知道的）如果你在电话里和妈妈或朋友聊天，你可以说（你知道的）“能不能跟进一下，甚至在 WhatsApp 上问我今天学到了什么”，然后（你知道的）把它复述出来，可以作为语音便签，或者如果你喜欢打字，你可以把它打出来，这样你就能真正加强这些神经通路，或者也许你可以考虑利用督导时间来讨论
some of the things you've learned recently or some of the things you've read recently so you could use a portion of those supervision sessions to get you practicing active recall or to get you practicing interview techniques and styles. If you're at uni or if you're learning in some capacity, then think about how you can test yourself among your cohort, the people you're learning with. How could you set each other little study sessions so that you can all advance? Because it's not a contest. It'd be amazing if you all did really, really how have you found this episode i hope you found it really useful if you have please do leave me a comment if you're watching on youtube please rate and review if listening on apple podcasts tell your friends about us tag tag whoever you like on socials um who think who you think might benefit from this
你最近学到的一些东西或你最近阅读的一些东西，所以你可以利用督导时间的一部分来练习主动回忆或练习面试技巧和风格。如果你在上大学，或者在某种程度上进行学习，那么考虑一下如何在你的同龄人、和你一起学习的人中间进行自我测试。你们怎么能互相设定小学习课程，以便大家都能进步呢？因为这不是一场竞赛。如果你们所有人都做得非常好，那将是多么神奇的一段节目啊，我希望你觉得它真的很有用。如果是的话，如果你在 YouTube 上观看，请务必给我留下评论，请评分和评论。如果在 Apple Podcasts 上收听，请告诉你的朋友们，在社交媒体上@任何你认为可能会受益的人
content um don't forget we've got those compassionate q a sessions coming up as well we've got the first one on monday the 13th of march 2023 at 7 30 p.m we've got the second on Monday the 17th of April 2023 also at 7.30pm and the third is Tuesday the 2nd of May 2023 at 7.30pm and if you'd like even more advice support and guidance do consider coming along to the Aspiring Psychologist membership where for £30 a month we can really help supercharge your skills, expertise and confidence to get you where you'd like to be. Thank you so much for being part of my world. I'll look forward to catching up with you for the next episode of the Aspiring Psychologist podcast, which will be available for you from 6am on Monday. Take care. If you're looking to become a psychologist, then let this be your guide.
这期内容（你知道的），别忘了我们即将迎来的同理心问答环节。我们的第一场在 2023 年 3 月 13 日星期一晚上 7:30，第二场在 2023 年 4 月 17 日星期一晚上 7:30，第三场是 2023 年 5 月 2 日星期二晚上 7:30。如果你想要更多的建议、支持和指导，请考虑加入“有志心理学家会员计划”，每月只需 30 英镑，我们就可以真正帮助你提升技能、专业知识和信心，让你到达你想去的地方。非常感谢你成为我世界的一部分。我期待着在周一早上 6 点发布的下一期《有志心理学家播客》中与你交流。保重。如果你正期待成为一名心理学家，那么让这成为你的指南吧。
With this podcast at your side, you'll be on your way to being qualified. It's the Aspiring Psychologist Podcast with Dr. Marianne Trent My name's Jana and I'm a trainee psychological wellbeing practitioner. I read the Clinical Psychologist Collective book. I found it really interesting about all the different stories and how people got to become a clinical psychologist. It just amazed me how many different routes there are to get there and there's no perfect way to become one and this kind of filled me with confidence that no I'm not doing it wrong and put less pressure on myself. So if you're feeling a bit uneasy about becoming a clinical psychologist I'd definitely recommend this just to put yourself at ease and everything will be okay. But trust me you will not put the
有这个播客在身边，你将迈向合格的康庄大道。这就是由玛丽安·特ント博士主持的《有志心理学家播客》。我叫亚娜（Jana），是一名心理健康实习从业者。我读了《临床心理学家集体》这本书。我发现里面关于所有不同故事以及人们如何成为临床心理学家的经历真的非常有趣。到达那里的途径竟然有那么多，而且没有成为其中一员的完美方式，这让我感到惊讶，这让我充满信心：不，我没有做错，这减轻了我的压力。所以如果你对成为一名临床心理学家感到有点不安，我绝对推荐这本书，它能让你安心，一切都会好起来的。但相信我，一旦你开始读，你就不会把
book down once you start. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
书放下。这期节目还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可留下评论。